stop wasting time you put things off
until tomorrow the next week because you
think you have a lot of time because you
think today doesn't matter today is the
most important day of your life make
something today that your grandkids will
be proud of stop boys and time go get
yours believe today is not the day to
give up I know it's hard but today is
not today I know you're tired but today
is not today I know you're down but
today is not today
you can quit tomorrow but not today not
today not today believe do you as much
as I love learning from others at the
end of the day you need to do you don't
try to be the next Elon Musk you don't
want the same thing he does you will
always lose trying to be somebody else
do you it's your only shot and it's a
great one believe if you want to grow
your business you need to over-deliver
like crazy just doing what your
customers asked for is not enough that's
what everybody does you need to far
exceed your customers expectations
that's how you get referrals that's how
you get customers for life that's how
you win I had a rough night last night
I'm exhausted but this is what
entrepreneur grit is all about it's easy
when it's easy but what are you doing
it's hard when everybody would
understand if you didn't show up today
I've got to show me what I'm made of
today believe come on Amelia Beijing
this is a quick reminder to bet on your
strengths you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and you'll never
ever ever ever ever ever win doing work
that you hate find the thing that you
have Michael Jordan level talent and go
all-in bet on your strengths good want
to believe nation today I challenge you
to see your challenges as fun but the
next time something doesn't go your way
the next time planes don't go according
to plan instead of getting angry you
smile because you're about to show
yourself and the world what you're made
of believe you need to stay consistent I
want on YouTube because I made at least
a video every single day for four years
while most people quit or lose steam
after three months every single day for
four years I promise you if you stay
consistent good things will happen keep
things in perspective whatever you're
going through right now whatever
terrible news you might have just
received remember that somebody has it
worse most of the world has it worse
than you right now and as long as you're
still breathing then you still got a
shot I
he is alone are not enough you are a
genius you have tons of great ideas but
lots of people die geniuses with their
ideas never realized knowing is not
enough you need to do the world belongs
to those who take action let's get it
your story matters why would somebody go
with you instead of some big company
that they already know and trust it's
your passion your why your story make me
feel how much you care and I'll spend
more to go with you tell your story I
only had four and a half hours sleep
last night because I was up late working
on my about page which is awesome I
can't wait to show you guys so today's
gonna be rough but I like it it's my
chance to show the world and myself what
I'm capable of I hope you make today
count and smile at your problems come on
believe nation whether you are working
today whether you are spending time with
your family today however you spend your
Saturday it's really really really
really important that you make every
second count
I've been working on a new project
called believe films where we made a
video on work ethic that we put a ton of
love into and this morning I got
obsessed with the thumbnail I want to
show you what my options are that's the
original that I put together from the
beginning that's version two that I
spent most of this morning working on
this is version 3 which is just simple
with some names below it and then
version 4 is a combination of 1 & 3 what
do you think let me know happy Sunday
guys what's that belief nation as you
can see I am starting to take my
Instagram game a little more seriously
it took me a number of years to get to
6,000 followers and a month I get the
7,000 followers and I'm spending outside
of YouTube my most amount of time
working on my Instagram I'm adding
videos like you just saw every day
pretty much pictures stories highlights
DMS I am very engaged at the moment and
if you are on Instagram and you want to
stay in touch you want to follow what
I'm doing outside of these videos
I would love to have you there I
appreciate the support telling your
friends tagging them I want to build up
that community and I'm really excited
about upping my game there being provide
more value and connecting with you as
well so follow me at Evan Carmichael
look forward to seeing you there thank
you guys so so so so so so much and if
you guys have any tips for me on my
Instagram strategy let me know as well
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching thank you follow me on
Instagram I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved and
I'll see you soon if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be
collect a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details